[Aplausos]
[Música]
os lo hemos contado aquí en visual
político aunque no es habitual oír
hablar de ello lo cierto es que en los
últimos años algunas cosas están
comenzando a cambiar en áfrica
[Aplausos]
desde el año 2000 la mitad de las
economías de mayor crecimiento de todo
el planeta han estado precisamente en
este continente
y ojo según las previsiones del fondo
monetario internacional en 2018 66 de
las 10 economías con mayor tasa de
crecimiento serán africanas países como
tanzania etiopía o costa de marfil se
posicionan a la cabeza del crecimiento
mundial
ahora bien áfrica es un continente
enorme formado por 54 países de tal
forma que podemos encontrar todo tipo de
situaciones países que crecen mucho y
países que no crecen tanto pero hay un
caso que destaca por encima de todos y
no precisamente porque las cosas marchen
bien por allí
[Música]
i
estoy hablando de sudáfrica durante
mucho tiempo la gran esperanza africana
amigos el sueño de nelson mandela de una
sudáfrica libre y prospera se ha
convertido en una especie de pesadilla
durante los últimos años las cosas se
han torcido el crecimiento ha
desaparecido los problemas raciales han
vuelto y la corrupción se ha extendido
por todo el país
[Música]
incluso el congreso habla de expropiar
sin compensación la tierra de los
blancos ahora bien en febrero cambió el
gobierno y uno de los hombres más ricos
de toda áfrica se convirtió en el nuevo
presidente podrá sudáfrica recuperar el
buen camino o estamos por contra ante la
gran decepción africana qué diantres
pasó para que en los años buenos se
terminarán corre la población blanca
peligro amigos en este vídeo trataremos
de responder a estas preguntas adelante
[Música]
la decepción sudafricana
sudáfrica es un país enorme es tan
grande como la suma de francia alemania
italia países bajos y bélgica y
representa ni más ni menos que casi una
cuarta parte de todo el pib del áfrica
subsahariana
[Música]
pues bien tras el fin del apartheid y la
transición democrática que comenzó en
1994 sudáfrica vivió una particular edad
dorada entre 1998 y 2008 la economía
creció de forma estable luego que
permitió que la clase media negra se
duplicará y que servicios tan esenciales
como el agua corriente comenzaron a
llegar a la mayor parte de la población
si con una economía grande una
democracia vibrante una prensa libre y
una gran cantidad de organizaciones
civiles todo parecía listo para que
sudáfrica lograra dar el salto que
permitiera brindar a todos sus
habitantes y no sólo a la población
blanca una vida cómoda y propia de un
país desarrollado en otras palabras se
esperaba que sudáfrica se convirtiera en
el ejemplo a seguir para todo el
continente
sin embargo espera un momento porque las
cosas no siempre resultan como se espera
y en 2009 todo este proceso terminó
desde entonces amigos las cosas han ido
de mal en peor
y la economía no crece el desempleo ha
escalado hasta rozar el 40 por ciento la
pobreza ha vuelto a repuntar y las
cuentas públicas están hechas un
desastre y no sólo eso las últimas
medidas anunciadas por el gobierno y el
clima de tensión social que empieza a
respirarse ha provocado incluso cosas
como esta el pasado marzo de 2018 el
ministro de asuntos internos de
australia peter de atom anunció
públicamente que su país
estudiaría conceder con un visado
especial de emergencia refugio a la
población blanca sudafricana que se
sintiera insegura en su país hubo un
ministro australiano hablando de dar
cobijo a los blancos de sudáfrica tan
mal están las cosas no era este el país
de la armonía y la reconciliación pues
amigos tal cual como lo escucháis pero
llegados a este punto la pregunta es qué
diantres salió mal pues podemos
encontrar a un gran culpable con nombre
y apellidos ya os hablamos por cierto de
él en un vídeo que os dejo en la
descripción sabéis quiénes hacen
[Música]
jacob zuma
el 9 de mayo de 2009 jacob zuma se
convirtió en el presidente de sudáfrica
a pesar de su controvertido historial de
polémicas con acusaciones de violación
corrupción e incluso crimen organizado
que se dice pronto menuda joya tumba
consiguió llegar al poder gracias al
apoyo de las clases populares que le
sentían como uno de los suyos
al fin y al cabo estamos hablando de uno
de los líderes más destacados del
movimiento anti-apartheid un líder que
durante diez años compartió cárcel con
el mismísimo nelson mandela el padre de
la actual nación sudafricana no me
diréis que es una mala carta de
presentación pues amigos jacob zuma
quien practica abiertamente la poligamia
y se calcula que tiene al menos 20 hijos
se vio obligado a dimitir por la puerta
de atrás el pasado 14 de febrero de 2018
repudiado por su partido el poderoso
congreso nacional africano acorralado
por la oposición y amenazado con una
moción de censura no tuvo otra
alternativa era marcharse por las buenas
o marcharse por las malas y es que los
casi nueve años que suma ha estado en el
poder han sido toda una pesadilla para
sudáfrica
veréis zuma llegó al poder con la
promesa de conseguir un país más
próspero y con más oportunidades para
los más pobres pero en vez de eso que
pensáis que hizo pues sí ni más ni menos
que convertir al gobierno sudafricano en
una especie de mina en un negocio
particular a su servicio y al servicio
de su círculo por cierto sabéis que fue
lo primero que hizo como presidente pues
gastarse ojo 23 23 millones de dólares
del presupuesto del estado en mejorar su
residencia privada una piscina por aquí
un anfiteatro por allí e incluso atentos
mandó construir un establo para vacas y
un gallinero para qué diantres kerry un
gallinero
[Música]
pero por supuesto eso no es todo el
pasado 16 de marzo la fiscalía nacional
anunció que presentaría cargos contra
jacob zuma por un acuerdo
multimillonario de compra de armas
buques submarinos y aviones de combate
que sudáfrica afirmó en los años 90
cuando zuma era el presidente adjunto de
nelson mandela con varias compañías
europeas amigos no estamos hablando de
poca cosa
esta compra de armas superó los 3 mil
millones de dólares el objetivo
declarado mejorar la seguridad nacional
el objetivo real enriquecer a tipos como
jacob zuma el acuerdo para la compra de
armas fue la pérdida más gráfica de la
inocencia de sudáfrica después del
apartheid y presagiaba la corrupción que
estamos viendo hoy david louis director
ejecutivo de colapso watch una
organización sin fines de lucro con sede
en johannesburgo y ojo este es sólo un
caso
decenas y decenas de casos más esperan
su turno si este tipo fue muy pero que
muy avariciosos en total se calcula que
las mordidas y las corruptelas de tumba
en su círculo le han costado a las arcas
públicas ojo más de cuatro mil millones
de dólares estadounidenses
ahora bien amigos si pensáis que esto es
lo peor
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados lo
peor de todo es que este presidente hizo
que el cáncer de la corrupción se
extendiera masivamente por todo el país
atentos
e
[Música]
el cáncer
jacob zuma siempre lo tuvo claro y de
hecho lo dijo abiertamente su partido el
congreso nacional africano era más
importante que la mismísima nación
sudafricana y que mejor manera de poner
por delante al partido que haciendo de
ahora sus líderes con los recursos
públicos sí creo que esto me recuerda a
algún que otro político si os ocurre a
vosotros algún nombre quién es para
vosotros el político más corrupto
dejadme lo en los comentarios y abrimos
debate pero continuamos el caso es que
he dicho y hecho
desde que zuma llegó al poder la
corrupción se ha disparado en todos los
niveles las empresas estatales son un
desastre hay profesores de matemáticas
que no saben lo que es una raíz cuadrada
pero que son afiliados al partido del
expresidente ya sabéis cómo consiguieron
el puesto y prácticamente ninguna
institución se ha salvado de la
corrupción
fijaos una forma muy curiosa de medir la
intensidad de la corrupción en sudáfrica
es fijarse en la calidad de las
viviendas que el gobierno construye para
los más pobres tal cual como lo
escucháis veréis si el presupuesto ya es
bajo cuando des contamos lo que se
llevan los políticos ojo no sólo dinero
también los propios materiales de
construcción al final quedan casas de
tan mala calidad que algunas se han
terminado derrumbando
otra forma muy habitual de corrupción es
apoderarse de los fondos para el
desarrollo de las zonas más pobres por
ejemplo para granjas lecheras
respaldadas por el gobierno el caso más
conocido es el de una granja promovida
directamente por montse vencían quien
llegó a ser ministro de minería con zuma
claro pues bien un buen día este señor
llegó a una comunidad pobre y prometió
construir una granja lechera financiada
por el gobierno supuestamente la granja
estaría controlada por los trabajadores
que se sumarán al proyecto a los cuales
incluso les prometió un viaje a la india
para aprender a gestionar esta
explotación o un viaje a la india para
aprender a gestionar vacas ya empezaba
mal la cosa dijo que quería cambiar
nuestras vidas nos dijo que este
proyecto venía del gobierno que no
tendría coste alguno que no podía no
gustarnos nos dijo que debíamos sumarnos
efrén de la mini agricultor que se
apuntó para formar parte de la granja al
final del gobierno se gastó 23 millones
de dólares los únicos que se fueron
fueron los miembros del coro de la
iglesia de este político y por supuesto
él se hizo de oro de la granja bueno no
está claro si se llegó a ordeñar alguna
vaca
[Música]
y esto es sólo un ejemplo de cientos en
los últimos años miles y miles de
millones para el desarrollo han sido
desviados perdidos por los líderes del
partido en el poder como os podéis
imaginar todo esto ha causado un gran
daño económico eso de invertir en un
país donde el político de turno puede
poner la mano o donde las cuentas
públicas están fatal digamos que no hace
mucha gracia pero ahora tras la dimisión
obligada de jacob zuma en su partido se
estaban poniendo nerviosos de cara a las
siguientes elecciones la pregunta es
cambiar a el nuevo gobierno las cosas
el cambio
el 15 de febrero de 2018 tras la
dimisión de jake
cyril ramaphosa otro histórico líder del
movimiento anti-apartheid fue nombrado
presidente ojo
no hablamos de un tipo cualquiera el
señor rama posa dejó la política a
finales de los 90 para darle el salto al
mundo de los negocios y sabéis que
gracias a sus influencias y a
empresarios blancos que querían tener
buenas relaciones con el gobierno
ramaphosa logró convertirse en uno de
los hombres más ricos del áfrica
subsahariano su fortuna actual se estima
en cerca de 500 millones de dólares
pues bien este nuevo presidente ha
prometido un nuevo amanecer según ha
dicho su política tendrá como
prioridades equilibrar las cuentas
públicas atraer inversión y luchar
contra la corrupción su lema
sudáfrica está abierta a los negocios
claro que de entrada ya se enfrenta a
algún que otro problema por ejemplo la
asamblea nacional aprobó en marzo poner
en marcha el proceso para cambiar la
constitución de tal forma ojo que el
gobierno pueda expropiar sin
compensación la tierra en manos de la
población blanca y amigos si finalmente
llevan a cabo esto está claro que la
inversión no va a llegar va a salir
corriendo pero en fin sólo el tiempo
podrá decirnos si este nuevo gobierno
logra que sudáfrica se sume a los leones
que están despertando por toda áfrica o
por contra el país continúa por la senda
del abismo pero ahora turno para ti
crees que tu gobierno el gobierno de tu
país lucha suficientemente contra la
corrupción déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
dale a like y no olvides suscribirte a
visual político un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]